the comic book phenomenon a
multi-billion dollar industry in a pop
culture revolution that has taken the
world by storm year after year and
decade after decade but none of this
would have been possible had it not been
for the creation of one superhero a
singular icon who is faster than a
speeding bullet who was more powerful
than a locomotive
and who could leap tall buildings in a
single bound this is the definitive
Superman
you
while the Superman that we know today
with the red cape and the blue uniform
didn't appear until Action Comics issue
number one in 1938 the origins of
Superman can be traced back to his
creation at the hands of Joe Shuster in
1933 as a telepathic villain bent on
world domination during this same year
Joe Shuster would introduce his creation
to fellow classmate Jerry Siegel who
would go on to publish this villain and
his own publication series titled the
advance guard a future civilization with
issue number three but the following
year as the two work together
Jerry Siegel would revamp the character
going through a series of drafts which
would ultimately lead to Superman's role
as a superhero and his publication with
action comics issue number one and to
fill you in a little and they're really
the beginning of it all in one night as
if it has been pod mentioned in the past
stories ideas kept coming to me and I
kept getting up again and again during
the night and just jotting down these
ideas and these scripts until very early
the next morning I dashed over to Joe's
house which is about ten blocks away I I
showed him the script of Superman the
entirely new concept in which there
would be a meek mild-mannered reporter
Clark Kent Lois Lane who scorned him but
who was who flipped over sort of as
Superman not knowing the Superman and
Clark Kent we're wondering the same
personnel you want to stay you want to
stay with you're the same enthusiasm I
thought it was a terrific idea and we
went right to work right then and there
you sat down at the drawing board
designing the way the characters yeah we
spent the entire day working on it all
afternoon and and we at the drawing
board
Jerry and I and I remember that the
matter of the costuming of Superman yeah
I remember two suggestions I made you
one that the letter s well be beyond
assess right I wasn't given a skin-tight
costume to to show up his physique for
one thing and then Jerry suggested
putting on okay okay so that when the
character zooms through the air would
give it a lot more action the movement
they look like he's really flying and
then very very head of course yeah yeah
you added all those additional things
like the the boots and the belt and the
yeah and the whatever I make it as
simple as possible with their newest
creation in hand Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster spent the next four years trying
to find a publisher trying to find
someone that would take on this new
character the Superman and bring him to
the mainstream now during this time
Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster would
introduce Superman to consolidated
publishing and the hope here was that
consolidated publishing which had
previously released a series titled
detective Dan secret operative number 48
would in turn paved the way for the
comic book industry of I extension allow
Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster to publish
Superman but consolidated publishing had
only published one story of detective
Dan and had no intention with moving
forward with the series and so while
they had sinned an encouraging letter to
Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster praising
their work Joe Shuster had taken this
rejection to heart and had burned all of
the pages of Superman with the exception
of the cover which was saved by Jerry
Siegel
[Music]